hello and good morning thanks for being
with us justice has been delivered the
message from the u.s president joe biden
as he said that the leader of the
terrorist group i'm an al-qaeda i'm i'm
an al-zawahiri osama bin laden's
right-hand man has been killed in a
drone strike in afghanistan addressing
the nation from the white house mr biden
set out how he authorized the action
which killed the man who is one of the
masterminds of the 911 at terror attacks
zawahiri was standing on the balcony of
a safe house in downtown kabul when he
was killed by two hellfire missiles our
u.s correspondent mark stone reports
he was quite literally osama bin laden's
right-hand man the doctor turned
terrorist who became leader of al-qaeda
when bin laden was killed by u.s navy
seals in 2011. his death now is the most
significant counter-terror operation for
the americans since then my fellow
americans
on saturday
at my direction
the united states successfully concluded
an airstrike in kabul afghanistan that
killed the emir of al-qaeda
iman
al-zawiri he'd been a wanted man since
the late 1990s a 25 million dollar
bounty on his head
in the end remarkably he was tracked
down to a safe house linked to the
taliban in the afghan capital kabul u.s
officials say intelligence located his
wife and children to a building in the
city for months they monitored it and
spotted zawahiri we're told the
president was briefed last month and
informed that the al qaeda leader had
been seen repeatedly in the house he
never left the building but was often
out on the balcony last week the
president gave the green light for a
strike and shortly after 6am kabul time
on sunday two hellfire missiles were
fired from a drone
he played a key role a key role in the
bombing of u.s embassies in kenya and
tanzania killing 224
and wounding over 4500 others
he carved a trail of murder and violence
against american citizens
and then there was 911 planned and
carried out with such devastation on the
orders of bin laden and zawahiri
he was an egyptian jailed in cairo with
other islamists in the 1980s
he became the brains of al qaeda the
guiding figure behind the public face
that was bin laden the americans are
claiming a great victory with his
killing president biden proving he says
that america doesn't need to be in
afghanistan to kill terrorists there no
matter where you hide
if you are a threat to our people the
united states will find you and take you
out
in the uk reaction from the mi6 chief
tough job professionally done by our
allies culmination of a long shared
effort since 9 11 to eliminate the
threat posed by zawahiri a man
responsible with his toxic creed for the
death of so many these past three
decades thoughts with their families
tonight
but here's the troubling reality for the
americans they have left afghanistan to
taliban leaders still happy and able to
harbor al-qaeda's leaders that's hardly
reassuring mark stone sky news in
washington
all right let's bring in our security
and defense editor deborah haynes who's
joining us now liver deborah good
morning to you so uh what does this tell
us about the taliban and their promises
and can we expect there to be reprisals
from this action
western officials will of course be
anticipating that the core al qaeda
group will be trying to avenge the
killing of their leader but
as our here he didn't inspire the same
kind of charismatic following as osama
bin laden the founder of al-qaeda and
the group's ability to launch those
spectacular terrorist attacks that
became synonymous with their brand at
the end of the 90s and the beginning of
the naughties has been significantly
degraded by the last 20-plus years of
counter-terrorism work in afghanistan in
pakistan around the world by u.s special
forces and spies and british
counterparts and others yet there is
going to be a lot of worrying questions
about the fact that the taliban which
has such a deep relationship with
al-qaeda
despite its promises to the u.s to sever
those ties was not just harbouring
leaders in afghanistan but allowing the
leader of al-qaeda to reside in kabul
clearly uncomfortable for the taliban
now we're going to see uh announcements
probably of who will be the replacement
to zoahiri and one thing is clear the
threat from terrorism while degraded has
not gone away
okay debra haynes thank you very much
for that
now the national flag carrier british
airways has suspended the sale of
short-haul flights from heathrow until
at least next monday after the airport
put a cap on the number of passengers
who could pass through each day and now
it comes the staff shortages have led to
long queues and cancellations our
reporter ashley hernan is here with us
now for more on this session good
morning to you so how concerned should
people be who are traveling through
heathrow in the next couple days this is
likely going to affect passengers who
are traveling domestically but also
throughout europe so if you're planning
to book a flight to either of those
destinations or any of those
destinations in the next week you won't
be able to this they say is to comply
with heathrow airport's cap on passenger
numbers last month the airport said that
every single day the maximum amount of
passengers that would be able to travel
would be 100
000 and ba in response said okay we're
going to cancel 10 300 flights up until
now up until october between now and
october and to try and limit the number
of people who are passing through the
airport some airlines decided to reject
that request from heathrow such as
emirates being one of them but with ba
cancelling those flights and not letting
new passengers who are wanting to book
onto short-haul flights go ahead then
that is a significant problem for
passengers who are already facing quite
a severe amount of disruption we're
seeing people struggling to get hold of
their bags there have been a breakdown
in baggage systems we know that airport
security
we've seen long queues there as well and
that's on top of thousands of flights
being cancelled every single day the
industry we know has struggled to cope
with demand there have been significant
staff shortage issues and a surge in
post-pandemic travel but he throws limit
and cap on the number of passengers who
are traveling that 100 000 mark is due
to be in place up until september the
11th so i guess the disruption will
continue for
us a few months yet and that will do
little to quell the nerves of people who
are due to gold holiday absolutely right
okay thank you very much for that these
are the latest pictures that we have
from heathrow of course people
will be traveling they're very concerned
about how long it's going to take them
to get away on holiday whether they'll
even be able to take their flights short
haul using ba rights now and we'll have
of course more on that throughout the
morning
but uh
in the last couple of minutes we have
had the latest results coming from bp
their figures have been announced um
as you can see there has been an 8.5
billion
pound profit in the second quarter of
this year
the underlying profits have been the
highest they have been in 14 years of
course this comes at a time when the
country's going through a cost of living
crisis people are struggling to be able
to pay for fuel for their cars but
british petroleum has announced huge
profits for the second quarter of this
year 8.45
billion
we'll have full analysis on that uh with
a helen and smith in just a few minutes
time
now the former tory leadership contender
penny morden has in taurus endorsed the
foreign secretary liz truss in the race
to become prime minister this is a huge
blow to rishi sunek now she gave her
backing to miss trust as she introduced
her at the latest conservative party
hustings call a mistrust the hope
candidate who knows what she believes
now during the event in exeter the duke
candidates once again clashed over tax
cuts and the economy now where does all
of this leave us in the race to succeed
boris johnson at number 10 joining me
for our daily polling pit stop is the
head of opinion polling we head of
polling research at opinion research
sorry chris curtis hi chris good morning
to you uh thanks for being with us so
look let's have a look at some of the
polls have come out in the last couple
of days or so from opinion uh let's
bring this one up this one compares
directly this trust from rishi sunak to
margaret thatcher
of all things
tell us what numbers we're pulling out
of this i mean there's the first
statistic there that people who've been
spoken to about this think that
which you see like is quite different
yeah there's a reason there's a reason
we do this which is that um people still
don't necessarily know quite a lot about
what the different leadership contenders
stand for they don't necessarily have a
strong view on their politics or their
political positioning and in situations
like that quite often what voters do is
they think about what's come before and
which leader they're similar or
different to and then they start to
associate them with that leader and that
forms quite a lot of um the views that
they form about them um and in this case
in britain at the moment it is still
true that margaret thatcher is one of
our most popular prime ministers in in
recent memory and that's one of the
reasons um
wishy soon axe uh
is straight isn't uh being associated
with margaret thatcher so much liz trust
is being associated with the numbers of
liz trust and this is not just to do
with the fact that she was pictured
sitting on top of a tank like margaret
thatcher famously was yeah i mean
obviously some of this is going to be
down to lazy comparisons uh to do with
the fact that you know liz trust is a
woman and liz trust is a conservative
but what we do know is that people do
quite like margaret thatcher and
therefore that association is probably
working for for liz trust and and
working less well for rishi sunak yep
let's take a look at how they're being
viewed as as potential leaders and this
is from the same from your opinion
polling as well all three leads have
fairly similar ratings uh when it comes
to who be the best prime minister yes so
without saying but if you sort of ass
yeah the two people who are likely to be
that's private uh the next prime
minister and the one person they'll be
facing in the run up to the next general
election all three of them now have
pretty similar ratings so here's liz
trust is 33 think should be good 37
things should be bad if we can
so that's a net score there of about
minus four
if you look at rishi sunak 41 good 44
bad a net score of minus three slightly
more people are aware of him know about
him
and then when you look at kia starm as
well again slightly higher um uh you
know slightly higher levels of awareness
38
good 42 bad a net score of minus four
all three similar leaders have fairly
similar ratings at this moment in time
will that tell us about the way that
people are viewing the person who's
going to be next prime minister well i
mean none of these are particularly good
ratings but what we're about to see is
one of these people probably less trust
let's be honest i'm about to become
prime minister
most of the time when somebody come
becomes prime minister they get a
honeymoon period they have an
opportunity to have a bit of a political
reset to set out a new vision to the
country that's what liz trust is going
to be trying to do when she becomes a
leader in september
how successful that is i think will
dictate the next election because she
has really big problems that she's going
to have to overcome in this country um
really big headwinds that are going to
impact the next election whether that's
the nhs or the cost of living crisis
how is she going to handle that how she
going to cope with that is she going to
use that honeymoon period to put her in
a good step good place the next general
election um possibly but if not i think
you know with these kind of approval
ratings and after 14 years in government
it's fair to say that labour would would
stand a good chance at that and it also
might say that people are cynical about
all politicians potentially who are
going to be prime minister what about
this one this is from redfield and and
wilton um this is talking about their
sort of the head-to-head of you who be
the better prime minister yeah um so i
mean what you've seen it not just the
top line numbers there but but the
change is underneath as well um is
pretty similar to what we've been seeing
quite quite across quite a lot of
polling over the last couple of months
which is liz truss's ratings going up i
mean you know you've got this where
she's you know now ahead of kia stammer
on the best prime minister but you've
also got questions about whether we were
just looking at whether she should make
a good or bad prime minister she's seen
quite a substantial increase
is that because she's getting all these
cabinet backers now do you think i think
so but what we're basically seeing is a
lot of conservative voters swinging in
behind her so previously her ratings
among those who voted conservative in
2019 weren't that great she's seen quite
a substantial increase in that and
that's why she's now looking in a much
sort of better position let's just take
a quick look at um versus rishi sooner
can the same polling if we can
i understand that we haven't actually
got that graphic so let's not do that in
tall because it's not there but let's
look at kistama because obviously
whoever uh wins this race will be facing
his time most likely if he stays
at the next election and
this is not great reading for the labour
leader
about how people
think that he actually what he actually
believes and how people should believe
yeah i mean look kierstarm is a few
years into the job now and i think it's
fair to say that you know lots of people
still don't necessarily have a clear
view of what it is he stands for um he's
still got time left to do that he's
still got time to set out her vision for
the country but he's going to need to
because you know if people don't
necessarily know what you stand for uh
they start making associations
themselves and those associations are
not necessarily things that kiyostan
would like yes one of the reasons that
you end up getting in these difficult
situations over strikes like he has in
the past few days people don't know what
he stands for so it's very hard for for
you know to not end up in a bit of a
mess in it when questions like this come
up so kierstama needs to start to set
out that vision um he needs to think
about how he's going to take this trust
on the next election ultimately that
vision is going to have to be based
around the economy and the response to
the cost of living crisis because they
are the most important issues to voters
yeah you ask you ask folks at the moment
what's the biggest issue facing you at
the country or your personal life
they'll say the cost of living crisis
and why aren't you why are you asking me
about anything else so labour needs a
response for how it's going to do better
than the conservatives um on that key
issue let me see the comparative as well
as to what people think about liz trust
and what she stands for right now if we
can bring that up
there we go what do we make of these
numbers yeah so you know liz trust
hasn't been you know so dominant in
politics necessarily over the past few
years you know she hasn't been asking
six questions a week to the prime
minister and there's a spatchbox or
popping up on the news most evenings
like kiyostama has so the fact that you
know a lot more people you know almost
as many people know what she stands for
i think is is quite telling and it does
show um the task that kiyostama still
has in front of him in setting out the
kind of person he is and the kind of
prime minister he would be and setting
out that vision to the country yeah
defining who is welcome that in the
conservative parties to find who is
right chris really appreciate your time
thank you so much for that all right let
me just uh remind you now if you need
reminding that rishi sunak and liz trust
will both take part in a live special
program the battle for number 10 here on
sky news it's going to be hosted by kay
burley it'll be on thursday at 8 00 pm
all right let's bring in our political
correspondent amanda who's joining us
now with the latest sir amanda good
morning to you we had some more hustings
last night didn't we
absolutely and there was a very dramatic
moment when penny mordant who was the uh
brexiteer former defense secretary
wildly popular with the party membership
narrowly pipped at the post to become
one of those two candidates in the final
run to be party leader pipped at the
post by liz trusts after a last-minute
surge in support from mps she was the
candidates whose endorsement both of
them wanted to hear and last last night
in a major piece of dramatic political
theater she came out in support for liz
trust who she described as the candidate
of hope someone who knows what she
believes in
saying she would clobber her opponents
very warm words despite perhaps some
blah blah blah bad blood between her and
liz trust's camps during the earlier
stages of the campaign now she's the
fourth of the defeated candidates to
come out in support of liz trust
following a whole roll call of other big
names cabinet big hitters over the past
few days and also this morning writing
in the telegraph andy street the mayor
of conservative mayor of the west
midlands
cynics might argue some of them have
been waiting to see which way the wind
has been blowing um perhaps hoping for a
job in a future liz trust uh government
but certainly the timing is key ballot
papers being sent out this week of
course now liz trust has a big
announcement uh today she's pledging a
war on whitehall waist saying she'll
save 11 billion pounds
from cuts to the civil service some of
it quite controversial um including
perhaps um
most controversially um cuts to regional
pay 8.8 billion pounds she's pledging
across the public sector um but it
remains to be seen uh what impact that
will happen we'll put some of that to a
backer of this dress jacob rees-mogg
will be on the program later amanda
thank you so much for that now still to
come as mps call for a body image
warning on retouch photos to be put into
law i'll be joined by the chair of the
health and social care committee jeremy
hunt
the minister for brexit opportunities
and the liz trust supporter as i said
jacob rees-mogg will be with me later in
the hour
and the labour party's shadow climate
change minister kerry mccarthy will also
be on the program shortly after 8 00 am
all right let me bring you a little bit
more on the breaking news that
just came in the last half an hour or so
the energy giant bp has announced its
half yearly results they have revealed
that they have made a
profit in the second quarter of 8.5
billion dollars let's bring in our
business correspondent helen ann smith
who is joining us from the newsroom good
morning to you helen and so uh huge
profits coming in from bp
yeah another reminder if we needed it of
just how well some of those big oil and
gas companies are doing at the moment bp
in the second quarter of this year
profits of 8.5 billion pounds just note
that up from the pretty big profits it
made in the first quarter
of
6.25 billion uh worth saying as well bp
not alone in this we had shells results
last week that company also doing
extremely well these profits this
morning are about three times as much as
the company made in the same quarter
last year so why well there's a few key
reasons
namely the massive surge in the
wholesale price in oil and gas that
we've seen that's partly because of the
pandemic disruption this huge surge in
demand that we've seen postpandemic and
of course uh the war in ukraine uh as
well and you might ask why this matters
so much why do we care that private
companies are doing well that's what
they set out to do of course and it's
because of the cost of living crisis
while these big profits being made many
many people struggling to pay their
bills and that was put into starker
focus this morning some new figures from
analysts about how much the energy price
cap is due to go up in october they've
said it could go up to as much as over 3
600 pounds a year for the average family
huge huge numbers and that's why there's
such a focus on these profits this
morning absolutely right okay hello for
now thank you so much for that
now the uh life support system of 12
year old archie battersby is set to be
turned off at midday today after the
court of appeal rejected his family's
request to postpone it further
twelve-year-old parents have said they
will make a final application to the
supreme court that is of course the
country's highest court to consider
their application for permission to
appeal
the bart's health nhs trust say that
archie is brainstem dead and that they
believe it is not in his best interest
to be kept on life support now i spoke
to archie's mum on the programme
yesterday
whether handed the letter over on
saturday night
with the
choreographed execution of my son which
just
it's just
as i say to the anxiety in my chest all
weekend i don't even know how paul's
felt we haven't actually spoke but he
hasn't even received the letter yet i
had to send him a screenshot you know
there was no meeting and sat down and
broken too gently it's this is what's
going to happen followed with a set of
military details you know things that
any parent
shouldn't have to go through
now an estimated one and a quarter
million people in the united kingdom
have an eating disorder with the number
of young people affected rising sharply
in the past five years now one nhs trust
has told sky news that the rising demand
for mental health and eating disorder
services since the pandemic is putting
more pressure on a health service
already under strain it comes ahead of a
report released today on the impact of
body image on mental and physical health
now the report makes 26 recommendations
to the government it says it should
create a new licensing regime for
non-surgical cosmetic procedures by july
of 2023
make sure consent for such procedures
includes a full medical and mental
health history and a 48-hour calling off
period
work with the industry and advertising
watchdogs to discourage advertisers and
social media influencers from doctoring
their images
and ensure that any commercial images
which have been altered including using
filters should carry an information logo
it also says that the government should
reconsider its decision to delay
restricting multibyte
for food and drinks high in fat salt or
sugar and implement it immediately our
health correspondent ashish joshi
reports
i remember being sat by myself a lot
eating lunch alone
becoming more and more withdrawn
lizzy was only 12 years old when her
mental health deteriorated
the struggle with food i always say was
born out of my trouble with anxiety
because
i felt so out of control with everything
in my life and i can remember
making almost like lists in my head of
what i'd been eating that day
and at one point it was just that was
the only thing that gave me that sense
of security
she developed anorexia as a way of
coping with her anxiety and depression
by 15 her weight loss became so serious
lizzie was admitted to a psychiatric
unit for 10 weeks of life-saving
treatments
it was walking into hospital and seeing
other patients there and hearing the
alarms and seeing the locks on the doors
so for a 15 year old in a psychiatric
unit of a hospital that must be
terrifying
yeah it was i was like wow i must be
really sick to be here i remember
another patient there who had cuts all
down their arm
and there'd be alarms going off
um where people had to be you know um
withheld i called my parents and i
remember just crying to them please come
and get me i cannot stay here and
and that was just because the chaos
around me
more young people are being referred to
mental health services than ever before
in our service since 2019 we've seen an
increase in 140 the rate of referrals in
dr dorothy newton and consultants in
eating disorders tell me social media
pressures around body image are helping
to drive the surge
i think that in many cases where a young
person develops an eating disorder is
often multifactorial but we have
absolutely seen many young people who
are
developing eating disorders who feel
that they have been influenced
by online content and that has led to
for example anxiety about their body
shape amelia goldsmith is well aware of
the precious social media can bring on
young people
that's why she uses her instagram
account to promote body positivity to
her followers now that i'm out of that
mental state i have the responsibility
to
show other people online that different
bodies are
you know completely fine and we can't
compare our pose bodies to someone's
completely natural body and i think for
me i
i need to also do it for my own mental
health and
i think
posting my body in a pose state but also
an unposted can really
make me realize that actually my body is
so different in so many different lights
angles everything like that
lizzy is now studying to be a doctor
one day she hopes to use her own
experiences with other young people who
need help
ashish joshi sky news west london
to say i'm joined now by the chair of
the health and social care committee
jeremy hunter good morning to you
jeremiah thanks for being with us um so
this report is is quite arranging it
makes a couple of recommendations but i
do wonder what's being said to the
social media companies to try and make
sure that they bring in these warnings
on images that they have been doctored
well good morning kamali i mean the
truth is as you say in that report the
world has changed very dramatically we
now think that around 60 of 17 to 19
year olds may have a possible eating
disorder so this is a very
dramatic increase over the last couple
of decades
and social media appears to be one of
the causes we call for some research to
be done so that we can properly
understand that but at a very minimum
when commercial companies photoshop
images to make people look
more thin than they would be in real
life we think that should be labeled we
think people looking at those images
should know this is not a real human
being and that's part of the way that we
can help people use social media with
more awareness
of some of the tricks of the trade if
you like and therefore stop this this
focus on ever thinner bodies which is so
damaging to so many young people
particularly young women
yeah i mean i mean you think that mr as
you as you were saying i'm sure many of
our viewers feel the same it does beg
the question why is it taking so long to
try and make sure that those kind of
rules are brought into place is it an
issue with regulation should there be
legislation brought in what's the hold
up because we've known about this for a
while
well um in fairness i think that mps
have been on the case for quite a while
and my colleague dr luke evans has been
campaigning very hard on this in
parliament um and i think the social
media landscape
is in need of an overhaul in areas like
this particularly when it affects young
people um but i think the most important
thing is the message we're giving in
this report is just not the case that
there's nothing we can do about this
there's the doctored social media images
there's also the fact that you've got a
lot of backstreet cowboys where you can
just turn up and get
non-surgical cosmetic procedures done
to change the look of your face the
shape of your nose
and we say that shouldn't be something
you can just turn up and get done on the
spot there should be a cooling off
period and in particular there should be
an obligation on whoever is conducting
that procedure to look into your full
history including your mental health
history and talk about that with you
because um it might be that this isn't
actually anything to do with your look
it's just to do with mental health
issues and the the thing to do is to
look at the root cause of those problems
not to change the look of your face
i mean is there enough support then for
people who feel like this we know that
we're going through a time of difficulty
in funding social care and of course the
nhs is there enough are there enough
professionals working in this field that
can actually address people's concerns
well we do say that access to nhs
services has not been uh as easy as it
should be and of course that's the case
across the board because of the uh the
postcode backlog and all sorts of other
reasons but i think our particular
concern is actually that in some ways
access is too easy
for people who are feeling depressed uh
or anxious about their body image
they can go and get these procedures
done
you know on the spur of the moment
without proper consideration and then
they find out that it hasn't actually
solved the root problem which was
concerned about their body image and the
other thing we say in the report this is
i think um
you know a big change in terms of our
overall way of thinking is that when we
look at school children
our focus to date has been very much on
whether they are overweight and we do
have a very big issue with obesity we're
one of the fattest nations in europe but
we need also to be looking at whether
people are underweight
and so what we recommend is annual
health and well-being checks for
children
in which people are underweight are
flagged just as much as people who are
overweight
okay
thank you for that uh jeremy hunt let me
move on if i can and ask you to put on
your former foreign secretary hat for a
moment i just want you to react to the
news we had coming in overnight of the
uh drone strike they killed them i'm an
al zawahiri
well no one's going to shed a tear for
this very evil man
but what i would say is this also sends
a very powerful signal to people who
have tended to underestimate the
strength of america and the west
and tended to say we're in decline and
and the future belongs to the china's
and the rushes of this world and i think
what this shows is the technology at the
disposal of the united states and its
allies remains the most formidable of
any in the world
and in the end sometimes we take a while
to get our act together but in the end
the west will react when our values are
under threat
and do you think there are likely to be
reprisals to this killing
well um
you always run that risk but in the end
i think what we've learned from what's
happened in ukraine
is that
sometimes weakness
is a bigger provocation than strength
and our enemies people don't agree with
our way of life don't accept
our values
need to understand that the west is
going to be strong and resolute
in the face of challenges to our way of
life which is open societies respect for
human rights not marching into other
countries
and not setting off terrorist bombs
now this guy was killed in central kabul
does this just confirm for us that um we
can't trust what the taliban say they
were not meant to be harboring
terrorists
i'm afraid a lot of people will draw
that inference and i slightly draw that
inference as well i think that
the withdrawal from afghanistan was a
very big low point
for many many reasons but this was the
most important thing of all we were
supposed to be negotiating
that afghanistan would not go back to
being a harbor for terrorists i think
this indicates that
we can't be sure that's not the case
okay uh jeremy hunt uh do appreciate
your time this morning thank you so much
for being with us
thanks kamali
okay now of course we are getting down
to the final few moments for the
conservative party leadership race we've
got the sky newser
debates taking place in a couple of days
time there was of course a hustings last
night where the um
third place when a penny mordant
actually endorsed liz truss to be the
next prime minister and of course the
next leader of the conservative party
there is uh of course as i said a debate
taking place on sky news at
uh eight o'clock on the 4th of august
it's the battlefield number 10. it's
going to be hosted by
k burley
and of course she will be putting the
questions to those who are trying to
replace boris johnson in number 10 of
course become the next leader of the
conservative party and our next prime
minister now one of those people who are
backing this trust to take that job
is the
minister for brexit opportunities mr
jacob rees-mogg and i'm very pleased to
say
he's joined us here in the studio jacob
rees-mogg really lovely to see you and
thank you for having me thanks for being
here first of all let's just speak about
what we heard overnight with jeremiah
which is talking about the um killing by
the americans of i'm an al zawahiri i
mean it's a it's a huge scalp to get
yes and it shows that people who have
waged act of war against the united
states will not be able to
retire peacefully to their beds that the
united states is
rightly going after people who have
created led to orchestrated mass murder
in the united states and around the
world now do you think that the west
then was naive or foolish to believe
that the taliban wouldn't end up
harboring terrorists
well
i think that terrorists have been in
afghanistan throughout this period and
that they didn't suddenly all disappear
that's one of the first questions it's
just a question of whether we've been
able to to track them down and that we
know the areas in which they have been
and so i think it's great surprise that
a terrorist has been found in
afghanistan nor would have it been a
surprise if terrorists been found in
afghanistan uh a year ago we're slightly
surprised that they were found in
central kabul i mean obviously bin laden
was in the border regions that's where
we think that many of them hide in the
capital
well um i the taliban has not been the
most uh aggressive suppressor of
terrorism has it so i don't think you
should be surprised by this
so but it's actually it's had a benefit
hasn't it because the americans have
been able to track him down and find him
which may have been more difficult if
he'd been hiding um in a more remote
area i mean how does this affect any
potential engagement with that
government that's running afghanistan
right now do you think well it's
difficult engaging with that government
anyway as we know and that's been an
issue in terms of
providing financing for that government
and the problems that people are having
in afghanistan the very serious
shortages that there are there and the
taliban government is
not a friend of the west to put it at
its mildest i think that's one way of
putting it of course let's move on to
the domestic politics now as i said you
are a backer of liz trust you would have
watched the hustings last week
i was actually doing a different debate
on behalf of um
liz in um for the bristol and south
gloucestershire conservative association
and what was the argument you were
making
for people tobacco well the three points
really one is that liz is best placed
economically that she has the right
policies that will help the economy grow
and tackle inflation secondly that she's
a fully committed uh brexiteer that she
may have supported remain in 2016 but
she's been one of the cabinet ministers
most supporting me in my breaks to
opportunities role
and third that she's shown leadership by
support she's shown for boris johnson
over ukraine but also her loyalty to
boris johnson now you know that one of
her own economic advisers is concerned
that her economic policies could put
interest rates up seven percent
well i think that misunderstands what
patrick minford has said actually i i
think that um
the independent bank of england will set
interest rates and we have a serious
inflationary problem and interest rates
have been going up and if you look at
what's happened in the united states
interest rates have gone up much faster
in the united states
that is something done independently by
the bank of england
since 1997 when gordon brown gave them
that independence what the government
has to do is to make sure that fiscal
policy
both works against inflation and helps
the economy to grow and that's the
difficult thing to do because you need
to keep expenditure under control and
plans have been announced how to do that
but you also need to take the burden off
people so they keep more of their own
money to help them through the cost of
living crisis and then you need the
third thing which liz has been strongly
advocating which the supply side reforms
that make the economy more efficient i
mean those tax cutting plans are one
thing and of course you will support her
uh moves to do that but this idea of of
kind of borrowing of betting on this 30
billion pound headroom as fancy
economics been described by some some
may describe it differently if you're
going to talk about fairy tale economics
i think suggesting that there will be
income tax cuts many many years into the
future is the finest fantasy because
mr sunac i believe um because
actually you will remember that um
both peel and gladstone said that income
tax was itself a temporary measure which
they had a plan to remove
in the mid 19th century in the 90s so
making suggestions the tax will be cut
in years to come
is the greatest uh fairy tale but when
you take the boring figures you've got
to remember that the obr's figure for
2021 22 was out by 106 billion pounds
the abr thought borrowing would be 106
billion pounds more than it was
so the fantasy has been with the
forecasters and what we need is to get
the theory of economic policy right and
then apply it and that involves taking
burdens of people
are you completely happy with this idea
of borrowing it doesn't seem to me like
as a true conservatives as you as you
are you would be very happy with the
state borrowing all of this money
against an economic outlook if i can
finish any coming out that we're not
certain about with this ongoing war in
ukraine
governments almost always borrow the
years in which the government actually
pays back debt
are very few and far between
what you're talking about is the level
of borrowing and is it proportionate now
if you look at the borrowing of the
state at the moment the total borrowing
excluding the quantitative easing of 875
billion pounds which is owed by the
government to the government so if you
net that off we're under 60 percent of
debt to gdp i think it's a perfectly
sustainable level let's just pick up on
some of the policy areas that liz trust
was mentioning
in the past a few hours this idea of
cutting the civil service i know that
you're a fan of that you left that
famous note telling people to get back
to work but do you think the idea that
uh cutting salaries perhaps perhaps
moving civil servants people who are
paid by the government out of london is
the right way to make sure we level up
the country there are a number of
savings you get by moving civil servants
out of london
you don't have the london waiting or the
london allowance and property costs are
lower outside london these are really
important benefits and it ties in with
leveling up because you're moving the
jobs out of london but at the same time
we need a smaller civil service we have
91 000 more people working for the civil
service than we did in 2016. we need to
get back to the 2016 level that on its
own will save about three and a half
billion pounds potentially more but it's
not just a civil service is it this
trust is also talking about anyone's pay
for the government's that involves
teachers that involves police officers
involves nurses doesn't it that's not
that's not the plan the discussion at
the moment is around around civil
servants okay and staying on the civil
service then there's this idea of
cutting some 326 diversity officers so
is the job done we don't need to worry
about the civil service being diverse
anymore no i i think ensuring that you
have diversity within employment is the
job of the people making the employment
decisions not somebody who is employed
as a diversity officer
it is a role for aren't they the experts
in how you make sure that the workplace
is diverse and how you make sure no i do
i don't think it works like that i think
that you need to inculcate this in the
people making the employment decisions
and in the um civil service commission
to ensure that you are employing the
best people from a range of backgrounds
actually leveling up is crucial in this
moving jobs out of london because you're
then opening it up to people living all
over the country rather than a very
narrow
london focus so i think it's an
important saving and some of the
nonsense that we've been getting
we had a um training program called
czech yo privilege now what earth is
that why is this taking your privilege i
think why is the civil service wasting
people's time with a course that doesn't
help people do their jobs better what do
we want from the school service we want
people to get their passports on time we
want people to get their driving license
on time we want the probate service to
work all of which have had problems we
also wanted to be a workplace where
people who are from different
backgrounds from diverse backgrounds
feel comfortable to work and won't feel
like they are right and that is
stigmatized by their colleagues that
isn't a job you give to somebody and you
lock away in a private room to
concentrate about it that is something
that you have in the fundamentals of it
and the people who are making it very
diversity officers who are working
towards that though
yes because i don't believe they're
doing anything useful i don't believe
they're adding to the diversity of the
civil service it's a job creation scheme
created by the work for the woke
mr rees-mogg i don't think that is
entirely fair about all those diversity
offices i think that many of them are
trying to
achieve the best that they can i think
they will be much better employed
getting people the public services that
they need let's just bring up another
little clip from last night's testing
you said you didn't pay attention
because you're doing something else but
this is what liz trust said about
nicholas sturgeon i think we can play it
i feel like i'm a child of the union
that i really believe we are a family
and we're better together and i think
the best thing to do with nicholas
sturgeon is ignore her i think she's
i think
i'm sorry
it's a bit difficult when she's first
ministered she's got a democratically
elected position just as you i'm sorry
she's an attention seeker
that's what she is and what we need to
do
is show the people of scotland northern
ireland and wales what we are delivering
for them
ignore her she's an attention seeker
what's that going to do to the union
when they are agitating to try and split
it up well of course they're agitating
that's what you've got to remember all
that nicholas sturgeon does is campaign
to break the union
education in scotland has been doing
badly health in scotland has been doing
badly public services in scotland have
been failing under the snp and what we
need to do is to hold ms sturgeon to
account for the failings of the scottish
government to deliver services for the
people of scotland and when she's
waffling on endlessly about having a
referendum and going to the supreme
court and all of this we need to be
saying hold on you're doing this because
you are failing to deliver for the
people of scotland and the united
kingdom government will have to deliver
people to scotland as well i know that
her point would be that that is the
reason for the snp that they want to
have an independent scotland and you're
not going to be able to achieve anything
further in terms of discussion by
ignoring them are you
well we have to deal with the arguments
for the united kingdom how did scotland
get through the pandemic it got through
the pandemic because of the support that
there was from the united kingdom as a
whole the united kingdom taxpayer helped
england scotland wales and northern
ireland as a union it was fundamental
the vaccine rather it was a united
kingdom's success was the united kingdom
that had the resources and the firepower
to help this country get out of cavite
before other countries to the huge
benefit of our economy whilst nicolas
sturgeon was doing daily press
conferences wanting them in a permanent
lockdown so i think she's very often
wrong she's always moaning um and that
we need to focus on how the union
benefits people you're very aware of how
comments like that and what this trust
said last night only calcified the
feeling in scotland that they want to
separate from no they don't what they do
is um the smp gets very cross
because the snp gets crossed it's its
permanent default state is a state of
mild fury a lot of it confected
what we need to do is make the arguments
about why the united kingdom is
successful for the people of scotland
and how the united kingdom as a whole
has helped the people of scotland when
the scottish government has consistently
failed in key public services okay jacob
reese welcome to some brexit
opportunities
my pleasure thank you very much thank
you
all right now
to the war in ukraine and a ship
transporting grain through the black sea
for the first time since russia invaded
ukraine five months ago is on its way to
lebanon our international correspondent
alex rossi is in odessa where the ship
left yesterday good morning to you alex
so what do you know about this ship uh
whereabouts is it is it on its way to
lebanon now
we're heading into turkish waters at the
moment it will head through the boss for
us
and it will dock in istanbul where we
understand it will be checked by
officials from the united nations from
turkey russia and also from ukraine that
is part of the agreement under the black
sea initiative which was brokered in
istanbul a couple of weeks ago
so that's the first ship a glimmer of
hope really that moore will set sail we
understand from the ukrainians that 16
are waiting at the port here and another
two tall ports in the odessa region
hopefully they'll also be able to leave
as well if this uh voyage goes smoothly
for the ship that set sail uh yesterday
and it is extremely important that this
deal does work there is a global food
crisis which is worsening in many parts
of the world particularly in the middle
east and also in the horn of africa now
after the inspection of this ship it
will make its way
to lebanon it's loaded with 26 000
metric tons of corn much needed of
course in that country but ukraine is
known as the bread basket of europe it
supplies large amounts of food crops to
the world and it's vital according to
the world food programme that that stuff
gets out to the countries that need it
most
alright alex in odessa do appreciate
that thank you
now china's envoy to the united nations
has warned that nancy pelosi's visits to
taiwan will undermine china's relations
with the united states
the leading democrat and speaker of the
house of representatives has landed in
malaysia and is expected to travel to
the disputed island later today or let's
get more on this from divya bopaland
she's the international editor at taiwan
plus uh divine thanks very much for
being with us so we are still expecting
ms pelosi to arrive in taipei in the
next few hours are we
well kamali no one's confirming it the
u.s is not confirming it definitely
officials here in taiwan are not
confirming it they've remained very
tight-flipped about and in fact the only
reference we've had to it from the
upper-level officials here was from the
premiere saying that they are
ready either way but
according to the state news agency here
in taiwan taiwan's military has raised
its combat readiness which means its
rates its level of which
it can defend itself china has very
clearly said that there will be resolute
they will take resolute action against
nancy pelosi visiting and that the
people's liberation army will not be
idly standing by while they haven't
exactly said what they will do the us is
also warning that china may increase its
aggression
they have clearly said again that it
will not perhaps be in the form of an
attack or invasion but definitely
intimidation tactics maybe more flybys
in taiwan's air defense zone or even
naval exercises closer to the taiwan
waters people here in taiwan have
remained muted somewhat but they are
concerned though not necessarily because
of the specter of china's aggressive
military action they've lived under the
shadow for decades but it's because of
what else china can do china's taiwan's
biggest training partner and china has
already said that a hundred firms from
taiwan
their products will be banned
affect people's pockets here
okay divia gopalan in taipei do
appreciate that thank you
now
over half of independent pubs in the uk
have had to reduce trading hours because
of a lack of staff with 15 saying their
business is no longer viable the city
pub group who run over 50 pubs in
several cities around the country are
calling for a major review of the
sector's business rates and an immediate
plan to reduce staff shortages well
joining me now is co-founder of the city
pub group that's clive watson uh clive
watson good morning to you and thanks
for being with us so just tell us why
are you finding it so difficult to
recruit stuff right now
because there's just a lack of
availability it's it's not a question of
pay
uh we're putting out adverts for jobs
we're offering very good levels of pay
good levels of bonuses good retention
but
there are very few applicants uh and
a lot of people have left the industry
and a lot of people have left the
country
and what's that doing to you the
underlying business i mean how how
damaging is it to the industry that you
currently get people to work in the in
the venues
well
the pub industry hospitality industry is
a labor-intensive business but like the
nhs you need able bodies to to perform
the tasks to provide in our case the
service to our customers um if you don't
have the bodies there
then um it's it makes that much more
difficult you have to cut back on the
the for instance the food offer that
you're providing
uh sometimes you have to cut back on the
hours so
yeah it's it's
it's slowly throttling the british path
so what do you want to see happen here
clive would you want is there a role for
government in this
well i think it's not just the
hospitalities as i mentioned it's the
nhs
farming industry it's construction
uh
social care workers
lots of what i call labor intensive
businesses
we need to have a flexible visa program
where people can come for specific times
say
two years they come specifically to work
in this country and to provide that
flexible labor force
they can slot into the industries where
there are in some cases chronic
shortages and provide that extra labor
so that the hospitality industry nhs
other instruments i've mentioned how the
the right amount of labor
to uh provide the level of service that
uh in our case customers uh expect
so sort of a similar sort of thing as we
see in the farming industry where you
can get temporary visas to bring workers
in seasonally
i saw an asking paper the other day that
um one of the leadership candidates is
talking about increasing the number of
seasonal workers and uh increasing the
period they can be here i think from
three months to six months
and that is a that is a start that's
identifying the problem
and coming up with a pragmatic solution
but that's just a drop in the ocean
we're talking about lots and lots of
sectors
uh that are as i say labor intensive
that need uh more access to
a flexible energetic uh
more employees
okay clive watson do appreciate your
time this morning and best of luck
finding some people to work in the
venues thanks for your time
all right thank you very much
all right let's take a little look at
some of the images that we saw in this
morning's papers that are like the looks
of this is one from the telegraph
a little shetland pony if you're a fan
of that show parks and rex it reminds me
of a little sebastian remember that now
this little guy who after a lot of hard
work was instilled as the unofficial
mayor of cockington in devon he was
voted him by villagers after gaining
popularity
for his therapy work during the pandemic
who wouldn't be happier after meeting
that little guy
that's look inside the times that brings
us a picture of a contestant diving off
the old bridge in bosnia that is
excellent excellent form it's part of
the 456th annual diving competition from
this bridge i've been doing that a long
time more than 30 people have braved the
23 meter dive into the river from the
bridge this guy got
10 points and finally sealed with a kiss
the daily express shows as a picture
that was entered in the comedy wildlife
awards not sure how happy that scene is
about receiving that kiss and i also
like the winking owl very cheeky